écoutez l'état d'esprit c'est compliqué
là on sort fin après quatre heures
d'audition
prenons donc on peut pas vous affirmer
qu'il est complètement serein mais c'est
bien ça devient prenant pour tout le
monde 30 heures après le début de sa
garde à vue
johnatan d'aval n'a toujours pas vacillé
lui et ses conseils font pourtant face à
un véritable déferlement d'éléments à
charge
il ya d'abord ce véhicule de société est
mise à la disposition de l'époux
d'alexia technicien de maintenance en
informatique pour une entreprise gré
l'oise un voisin l'aurait entendu
démarré à 1h30 du matin la veille de la
disparition de la jeune femme
un témoignage corroboré par les analyses
des mouchards de l'utilitaire un voyage
nocturne que n'explique pas le gardé à
vue
il maintient qu'il a passé la nuit chez
lui or se pose une véritable difficulté
at il réellement ou pas passer la nuit
chez lui en l'état je suis incapable de
vous affirmer ou de vous confirmer la
version de joe natale alexis aura-t-elle
disparu avant son présumé jogging la
question se pose d'autant plus que des
empreintes de pneus correspondante
auraient été relevées à proximité du
corps de même qu'un drap ou des
fragments de drap un bout de tissu
suffisamment particulier pour ne laisser
aucun doute quant à sa provenance
c'est ce qu aurait démontré les
perquisitions menées au domicile des
époux d'aval sur les draps écoutez il ya
des éléments
il ya des éléments vous ment sera
davantage et on s'expliquera davantage
quand on aura accès à tout le dossier
puisque pour l'instant ces éléments
n'ayant pas accès qui a été d'un point
qui
reste en suspens john est à n'est pas
soupçonné par hasard c'est une réalité
il ya des éléments sérieux car même les
enquêteurs donc je j'analyse les choses
froidement et en l'état je ne suis pas
là pour dire si jo d'athènes est
coupable ou innocent il ne sera accordé
que peu de répit à johnattan d'aval lors
de cette journée à 16 heures son avocat
est rappelé en urgence pour une ultime
audition qui aboutira aux aveux du marié
pleurer johnattan d'aval reconnaît avoir
tué son épouse par accident après la
dispute de trop
il dit avoir agi seul pour dissimuler le
corps le jeune homme aux larmes si
facile et abondante que tous considéré
jusque là comme une victime vient de
changer de statut
[Musique]